[Musique]
ouverte en novembre dernier après six
années de travaux la station auber du
réseau express régional a doté le coeur
de paris d'un complexe souterrain dont
le gigantisme n'est pourtant pas
synonyme de démesure c'en est fini ici
du style nouille du métro en 1900 mais
une constatation s'impose cette station
simplon cher sans la faune habituelle et
les ceintures fort du vieux métro est
relativement peu fréquentées
alors serait ce megalopolis alphaville
le métropolis sans jeu de mot avec 225
mètres de longueur 4 kilomètres de
couloirs 73 escaliers mécaniques qu'un
ascenseur ou n'est-il pas somme toute
normal et logique d'une telle station
n'affiche pas encore complet
la plus belle station j'ai vu dans le
monde j'étais déjà projeté annuelle
d'hiver
bob arum et au point de vue de
fréquentation à ce que vous pensez
qu'elle draine déjà à elle de décider de
répondre à chaque fois que je viens jeu
à peine si nous sommes si celui ci j'ai
eu l'impression de débarquer dans un nom
de nouveau un petit nouveau en quel sens
anticipations se connaissaient pas du
tout c'est pas désagréable on a envie
d'y flâner
on est moins pressé de santé la
déception est plus vive du côté des
commerçants riverains ou en sous sol ils
ont même lancé une campagne publicitaire
sur les postes périphériques pour
appâter un chaland qui semble se dérober
les conséquences ont plutôt été mauvaise
moi j'ai perdu en ce qui me concerne
pour être généreux dix ans les trois
quarts d'heure devant commerce ceci au
moment des travaux et depuis vous n'avez
rien à perdre et rien récupéré alors
après celle aventure dont on fait un
effort disons essentielle pour
l'aménagement nos magasins de nos
vitrines mais là s'il s'avère cette
expression utilisée pour l'instant c'est
là peut-être nous apporter quand même
quelques clients de sur cette ligne pas
pour l'instant pour l'instant il faut
alors voilà long terme lorsque la rue
aubert sera dégagée entièrement je crois
que là ça pourra nous apporter vraiment
de tout autre client une nouvelle
clientèle
rien de déroutant dans tout cela pour
les responsables de la ratp qui ont
plutôt bonne conscience et après un
demi-siècle d'immobilisme son fortès
d'être maintenant en avance
combien de personnes fréquentent
quotidiennement la station auber
nous avons chaque jour
vingt-quatre mille personnes qui
seraient partis 112 milles qui entre à
la station auber et d'ouzbine qui
sortent de la station auber en
provenance de charles de gaulle-etoile
fait de la défense
ne sommes nous pas quand même en deçà
des prévisions initiales
je ne pense pas parce qu'il n'y a jamais
de prévisions spécifiques fait pour une
ligne limité entre la défense et obère
le public du métro parisien n'est pas
foncièrement conservateur mais n'est-il
pas un peu désorienté par ces
installations d'un caractère nouveau le
public est certainement désoriente des
forces et installations d'un caractère
nouveau
malgré tout après dix ans une période
d'adaptation qui est dure à peu près
trois à quatre mois le public se
reconnaît très bien dans les stations
modernes et les trouve très agréable
donc que l'on se rassure on n'a pas vu
trop grand dès octobre 72 le
prolongement de saint-germain-en-laye
doublera le trafic actuel et dans six
ans la jonction avec la nation verra
aubert tourner à plein rendement
[Musique]